my style I feel like translated over
well because that was the way that I
wrestled I didn't do all of the funky
stuff I was still very basic meat and
potatoes but uh yeah yeah I was very
basic but I worked at it diligently to
where where's the party do it come from
how dare you it's crazy because I
haven't ran in three years
I haven't all I do is run because I have
bad knees so I can't run anymore so what
do you swim I I do I do some pool work
but I do everything that I do I do it I
do it at a hard pace you're not doing
road work no I'm not doing road work and
mentally also I pushed myself in that
aspect because I know okay I'm not doing
cardio so I got to do this harder I got
to get it in other so I live on the
airline I work on the rowers sometimes
as well you know I work in the pool
wherever I can to get extra cardio and
to make up for what I'm missing and pile
on top of it there's a bunch of Fighters
telling their coaches now look he
doesn't do it the champ doesn't do road
work